in 1975 Russians and Americans shook
hands in space and overture to
collaboration the new director-general
of the european space agency wants to
strengthen the bonds that space
exploration has forged the guns I think
it's urgent to use space travel to
promote international cooperation that
goes not only for Russia but for all the
countries on earth I lady the other
expedia how is tricky stuff here I would
ask all sides to avoid calling space
exploration in the question by declaring
a boycott even in crisis situations the
space program should be a tie that binds
like science in general space travel has
fascinated me since early childhood this
inherent curiosity that we humans all
have in me it's especially oriented
toward technology and the Natural
Sciences when I was three my father told
me about the Sputnik was i impressed he
even showed me the Sputnik in the sky
although you couldn't really see it but
I actually believe that I saw is in toy
today we're in a new and completely
changed phase of space exploration
international cooperation is important
value right now the European Space
Agency is backed by 22 member states
plus Canada we know what international
work means and that's why I ISA is an
ideal mediator between the various camps
and east and west ogden best the civil
engineer who's coming to ISA from the
German Aerospace Center has eight years
of experience with both networking and
balancing disparate interests valuable
experience for his future work with the
agency and he's had a ringside seat in
recent space travel history like when
the Rosetta space probe woke up and sent
out the research robot feel a to land on
the comet churyumov-gerasimenko
the sentai Ronald these are simply
thrilling moments like the first moon
landing or Yuri Gagarin strip into space
there are high points again and again
and the Rosetta mission is definitely
one of them she didn't without phone
constitu Mohammed the violin and both
Germany in Europe we've now reached a
position that is recognized around the
world and we should now use this
recognition to push truly global space
projects I love on pathway active on the
time had fun the first idea I suggested
was a mission to build a permanent
station on the far side of the Moon us
an apartment in testosterone off the
body from there researchers and
engineers could prepare humanity's next
steps into space the lunar station
project is conceived to be one that's
open to any country involved in space
travel that was I can be in the future
such a project would help us even north
to use space travel to build bridges
when it comes to problems here on earth
is a problem in vic so valleys yet
you